today I will talk about counting and
sampling in first order loic and I will
mostly try to convince you that this is
an interesting
problem and yeah maybe I will have to
skip something maybe have to see and I
will start with the counting
problem so specifically with uh what we
call first order model accounting but
this is the symmetric version of that
problem
okay so first without any vades we call
this first order model uh counting and
we just want to count the number of
models of a given sentence over uh some
given domain let's say this the domain
will be always numbers from one to n so
n will be the parameter we will be
interested in when we talk about
complexity of this
problems uh so as I mentioned I will be
talking about the symmetry version of
the weighted uh for solve the model
counting problem here the Symmetry is in
the fact that uh the weights that you
saw yesterday you could have different
weights for every possible ground atom
here all uh atoms that come from the
same uh relation have the same weight
and they have uh positive we and
negative we right and then the task is
just to compute the sum of of all the
models of the given sentence five okay
so we want to sum the dates of these
models and this is uh there applications
but to I what I want to mostly sell
today as an application is uh
combinatorics so like if you want to
automate uh solving uh let's say
enumerative combinatorics questions that
uh let's say undergraduate students can
learn to uh
solve
and for that let's take a look at a
couple of motivating examples so here we
have the sentence F which defines a
relation e which is uh irreflexive and
symmetric right so when we uh count the
number of models of this sentence over
domain of size n what we are counting
are actually undirected graphs on N
vertices here's another
example uh how we Define fun to students
when we introduce them to relations well
we tell them a function is a relation
such that for all X we have exactly one
by such that rxy is true right so if we
compute the first order model count of
this sentence on the domain of size n
what we getting is the number of
functions on a set of n element so it's
n to
n we can add something more so we can
also say that for every y there's also
One X that next to it then we are
counting
permutations then
first here's a bit more uh interesting
example here we have a sentence that
defines K regular graphs so we say that
again this part we already saw right
that's uh undirected graphs and here we
say that the degree of every vertex is
okay so when we compute uh the number of
models now we're counting K regular
graphs on M
vertices and it turns out that all the
examples that I have just shown you are
counting problems that are tractable
right this is a result of many works
that started with the vs by he and uh
others and in those Works they first
showed that
fo2 uh is seable in the sense that for
every fo2 sentence you can compute this
first this F
first in time polom in
N then this was uh quickly complemented
by intractability of
F3 uh in paper by beam V and
S and then people started looking into
other classes not as strong as F3
because well we can't hope for that so
for instance kmic
make introduced uh these two classes
that are a bit difficult to explain but
they actually have then puds show that
you can take uh this fo2 which is the
first or logic with just two
variables and you can add one
functionality ACC to right so you can
say that one of your relations uh
satisfies
uh this
thing and then we also extended this
further into the logic uh C2 which is uh
extension of this result so here we
allow uh still two variables but an
arbitrary number of uh Counting
quantifiers counting quantifiers well
that's the counting that's quantifiers
that look like this so this one says
that there exist exactly K elements that
have some property this that there
exists at least K this one that exists
at most K and then we did uh some
extension of that as well I will not uh
cover them uh
today now uh I will show some
applications that we tried mostly
uh the combinatorics
applications so first one is uh about
counting the arrangement so suppose that
you want to run a secret Santa for your
research group and let's say you have
simple rejection sampling
protocol so you throw names of all the
people in your lab into a head and you
let people draw the names from this and
then there's someone who got their own
name you say okay we failed let's
repeat and now the question is what is
the probability that the first draw
succeeds right
so this is a very old problem that was
solved already in 18th century I think
well I'm not sure by whom but probably
or some
other like this
so uh it was solved it's known as
Counting derangement
but if you want to solve this you need
to remember at least what you had in
undergraduate comparator
classes so for many people this is non-
trial so it would be nice to H kind of
automate this kind of uh
problems so let's take a look at how we
could solve this using
counting uh of course this is not the
language that we want would want to give
to the users they would probably find
this
even more difficult than uh soling the
original problem but this think of this
as an intermediate language to which we
might compile some user friendly
language that we don't have yet so what
we do here is in the numerator we Define
the arrangements right which is
permutations without fix point so this
part we are saying R is a permutation
then here we are saying it doesn't have
to
expon and in the denominator wejust the
number of all permutations because when
we let the people draw the names from
the head what we are doing we are
sampling a permutation uni and we
succeed if that permutation doesn't have
fixed point so if no gets
the so and there are more problem like
this and we are also not the first to
try to use lifted inference techniques
uh for uh solving uh questions from
let's say Elementary and numera
combinatorics for instance there was
quite a recent paper from this year by
to
David and Kimi called lifted reasoning
for combinatorial
counting and that they design a spe
special algorithm for solving problems
that are close to uh the bfold base uh
from I think it's from
St and uh
that works quite well for that kind of
problems but the language is a bit
restricted so they mention problems that
cannot be solved by that approach and uh
all of them can be actually solved using
first Lookout so for instance this one
you have nine chairs in a row that are
to be occupied by six students and
professors Al these three professors
arrive before the six students and
decide to choose their seats so that
each Professor will be between two
students how many ways can they choose
their
chairs and this can be solved using for
mod Accounting in a fragment called C2
plus linear order so uh that's another
tractable
fragment and you can solve problems that
involve uh configurations of like let's
say
sequences and you can comine that with
gra you
can so we can solve problems like this
and also in
combinatorics people kind of realize
that you don't always have to look for a
like say closed form solution you can
also just say that you care about
whether uh your counting problem
actually is trable so there's very nice
paper by Igor p uh go complexity
problems that deals with uh these things
so in a Nell combinator lists uh care
about these problems as well they just
don't look at them as accounting models
of first order
sentences and then an application that
we actually uh did so this was more like
to words an application but one that we
did so you probably know the online
encyclopedia of integer sequences which
had been established by Neil Sloan in
1964 of course back then still just in
print
because
that's so this database works as follows
say you have a sequence of integers and
you would like to know if someone has
already studied it and perhaps has
already found something interesting that
might help you right so you type your
query here hit search and if you're
lucky the sequence that you're
interested in will be in the database so
in this uh case it was number of Threes
with and unlabeled nodes and the
sequence was one two 3 6 11 and
so
but this existing database of course
contains only things that someone has
already worked on because that's how
sequences get into this database you
work on it you find interesting sequence
you uh submit it reviewers check it if
they like it they include it into the
database but what if you are the first
to work on a problem that leads to some
uh sequence right then this existing
database will not help you so we thought
well at least maybe we can create a
database of uh
sequences that are defined by short
first Urologic uh formulas in this uh
fragment C2 about which we know that
it's tractable which means we can kind
of compute uh these sequences so this
database that we constructed contains
sequences that count models of
automatically generated uh sentences so
there's like uh things you need to take
into account many sentences give rise to
the same sequences because they're
combinatorial equivalent and so on but I
will not talk about
that uh I'll just show you that for
instance what happens if you introduce
numbers uh 1 2 six and 24 if you type
them into our search box well you can
recognize that these are factorials
right so what you get as a result here
is an entry that was automatically
constructed which actually defines
permutations almost in the same way as I
showed you before it's just that here it
doesn't use the counting quantifier
because actually you can Define that
with just one of
them so and then we also link this with
the existing database just if something
already exist there of course you will
find more information there but you may
have a sequence about which you don't
know that it even has some combinal
interpretation and if you're lucky you
might find this interpretation in this
in this
database
so uh it's available online well this is
a homepage of one of my students uh most
people when they see this slide ask
a very non-technical question can you
really have a domain name that ends with
do ninja and the answer is yes the
student has it and it
works so uh there you can find the let's
say demo version of this uh
database and
sometimes we even found like
combinatorial interpretation for a
sequence that was in uh the existing
oeis database that didn't have uh Bal
interpretation there there are just few
such cases but even that is
interesting and some most of the SE
sequences that we find actually are not
contained there so that's kind of the
purpose with which we built
it so uh I suspect I may have time for
this part so I will try to tell you
something about this so so far it was
very non-technical what I told you and
now I was thinking I would at least
sketch how the algorithms actually work
because a nice thing about this is that
we rely on an algorithm for sentences of
this form that was given already by van
and Brook in 2011 and another one was
also given in 201 by Beam at all and we
use it as blackbox and all the rest is
just uh doing uh transformations of the
sentences in C2 into simpler and simpler
forms that can eventually be handled by
using this as kind of
Oracle so let's assume we have the
algorithm uh for this for
counting uh Ved model count of uh given
sentence in this
form to extend this into
fo2 that's what was already done by V
Brook Mar and darish in 2014 in their KR
paper where they introduced a very
clever skolemization it's a different
kind of skolemization than what you may
know it doesn't use any function
symbols it uses negative numbers and it
preserve as model counts so here's an
example suppose this is the
sentence for which you would want to uh
count the model count compute the model
count so you can convert it into a
sentence that looks like this it's just
Universal
Quantified and it introduces a new
predicate s and this new predicate has
ne8 minus one you could convince
yourself that this works but in the
interest of time I will not do that so
just believe uh these
people okay so now we have uh something
that can compute model counts weighted
model counts for F2 sentences and now we
want to extend that into C2 so the first
thing we will
do we will observe that if you have the
weighted first order model count the
symmetric one it's actually a
multivariate polinomial in the weights
of the predicates so it's not too large
it's just polinomial so we can actually
compute this polinomial you can use for
instance uh polinomial interpolation to
get the coefficients of all the monomals
and that means you can compute model
counts with what we call cardinality
constraints this a cardinality
constraint that's an expression that
looks like this it says that your
relation R for instance let's say it's
binary uh it's size like number of true
atoms can be has to be equal to K and
then for Q you can have L and so on
right and this all you can do because
you can think of this weighted for model
count as just multivaried polinomial and
you can extract its
monomials and to do that you just need
to call that Oracle that we constructed
in the previous step using the idea of b
r m and
darish so now we have fo2 Plus card
constraints next we can show how we
would handle sentences that look like
this this already contain counting
quantifiers
right so to get a simpler
example let's assume that we have just
one constraint with accounting
quantifier here which says that we have
some relation r that satisfies that for
all X you have exactly k y such that
this rxy is true so you can imagine it
as like directed graph where every
vertex has out degree R and it's somehow
constrained also by this F and there can
be other relations
as now we will want to use what we
already have to compute the model count
of this so we introduce binary
predicates F1 to
FK we say that every x uh for every X
there is some by such that f iix i
so see now from each X we will have like
these labeled uh edges K of them for
each and this
distinguishable now we say that this R
relation has to be covered by these fi
and vice versa you cannot have uh f i
without uh
RS then we say that these uh FIS
actually have to be disjointed right so
they cannot lie on each other and
finally we say that the cardinality of R
is K * n so this forces this are
relation now to satisfy this
constraint
so we can compute the number of models
of this sentence now but we have to be
careful we have to divide this by K
factorial to the N because for every
domain
element we can permute uh the FIS right
how they like from so that already gives
us an algorithm for dealing with
sentences that have this
form then we need to extend this even
further into uh full
C2 and that's a bit more involved so I
will skip that if you're interested uh
yeah you can check the paper but it's
similar kind of
Transformations so the end result is
that we have an algorithm for counting
models of C2 sentences and we obtain it
by just uh calling algorithm for this
Universal Quantified uh F2 sentences so
if you want
to uh optimize let's say speed up
algorithms for this you can focus on
just optimizing the one with the
universal quantifier and two variables
so that kind of simplifies also the
design of algorithms and we did
something uh along these lines with Tim
van preman like two years ago and it
really managed to speed up these things
so it works and then in the
remainder uh of the talk I will
introduce the corresponding sampling
problem
because uh it's a bit different than
what you encounter in proposition
setting
so first let us Define the problem so we
are again given a foror theologic
sentence then uh some domain again let's
say numbers from one to n and for the
first order model sampling problem we
want to uh draw a
model uh of the sentence
uniform so here is an example this again
is the sentence we saw a couple of times
today it defines undirected graphs so in
this case the first order model sampling
problem gives us a
uniformly undirected graphs uniformly at
random then we have also the weighted
variant of this problem where we
introduce the weights of uh a possible
world in the exactly same way as for
model counting and we want to sample
models with probability proportional to
derates and this can already be used for
instance for sampling from Mar
networks and other srl
systems but in what follows I will talk
about just about just the uned version
of this problem because
it's so why I said that this is
different than what you're used
to from the propositional setting well
the reason is that in the propositional
setting if we know that we can count
right models of uh uh some let's say
propositional formula then we can also
sample and it's quite simple we go over
the variables we pick uh XI compute the
models where XI is false then compute
the models where it's true then we sampl
the value according to this probability
then we set the value and we repeat
right that's what we can do if we have
the propositional
setting but this doesn't work in the
first order setting where we have the
symmetric weighted model counting that's
tractable because if we want to uh do
conditioning like this we hit the issue
that this is Sharpie hard so V then
Brook and Davis they showed that you
can't add uh binary evidence arbitrarily
and this also corresponds to having
asymmetric
weight which is also a problem that's uh
well that you have less tractability
what about the approximate varant of
this problem uh of the first order model
sampling yeah condition is approximate
counting also hard
or
uh I well I think this is not no there's
like if you have like bounded buly rank
so you can kind of decompose into block
structured uh models then you can still
do conditioning in uh in the time but uh
about approximate version I don't know I
don't think anyone looked into it but I
might
have uh okay so this is what you cannot
do
uh so you need some different approach
and if you only looked at this uh
Universal Quantified sentence that I had
like that before to which we reduced
everything from the model counting
setting then
uh yeah that would be kind of easy that
we sold uh year ago or two years
ago uh but then if you actually have uh
existential quantifiers the problem is
you can't use this trick with uh
converting back to this universally
Quantified case because the
schiz introduces negative eight and for
sampling that's a problem right because
it makes sampling IL defined
because you have possible worlds with
negative
eights mods with negative so it's a
problem so we need a different approach
but fortunately we can show that uh you
can also sample from uh models of C2
sentences and time polinomial in
n and well I have a bit of time so maybe
I can sketch how we do
it so first be sample all the unary
atoms that's actually something that's
easy and can be done using the
techniques similar uh that we had for
introducing cardinality constraints it's
the same kind of way but then for the
binary atoms we need to use something
that's similar to if you know domain
recursion so you take the domain element
I and then sample all binary atoms that
involve this uh domain can you check
check which uh existential constraints
on the
other domain elements from the set one
to I minus one are now satisfied and you
remove them at then new
recurse so here is just quick example
how that works so here we have a problem
where we want to sample undirected
graphs where every vertex is connected
to some vertex that's uh labeled by Blue
right so first as I said we sample the
unary atoms which in this case are just
the
blues so let's say it was one and
four now we introduce auxiliary
indicators here which tell us us if this
existential constraint is
satisfied for that domain element so now
you see it's not satisfied anywhere they
are all
throning
now we start with this uh I equal to n
in this case four and we will sample all
the binary atoms while they are true
values that involve for so all possible
edges we need to consider and we have
these uh configurations that are
distinguishable the address you can get
as isomorphic to this this two we don't
even need to uh look at because here
four is not connected to any blue vertex
so this will not lead to any models so
these two we can
cross and what remains are these to
compute their weights with which you
should uh sample them well we need to
use the oracles for uh counting in C2
which we derived on the previous slides
so we can compute probabilities with
whether we should sample configuration
like this or this or this
one and then once we sample this we just
need to sample among those uh
configurations from the same isomorphism
class so let's say we sampled we
selected this van and then from those
isomorphic vs we selected this so this
is what we have now we update the
indicators so these are all happy now
because they're connected to uh blue
vertex this one as well so we recurse to
the small one and we continue like this
it's the same
idea and eventually this is OB
be and this might have interesting
applications because for instance if you
look at standard programming language
libraries you have support there for
sampling some simple combinator
structures like parations
combinations uh stuff like this
but if you need something a little bit
more uh complicated you need to write
your own s right so it would be nice to
give people some tool that uh could do
this and where you would know which of
these problems are in polinomial time
and you would just descri it and the
syntax would tell you it's
direct so that might be an interesting
application of this and to conclude my
talk uh we can count ample models of C2
sentences we can go even beyond that but
I didn't cover that in this uh yeah so
thank you very
much we have
questions can you
use can you use the sampling that you
described to estimate the number of
models uh yeah you you can use it to
estimate number of models uh beyond the
tract table fragments let's say uh you
could try to estimate uh like something
about let's say transitivity that you
cannot represent here but you don't
really get like U nice uh like you don't
get like these multiplicative Epsilon
Delta cures that's probably not but I
think you could use this in important
sampling
algorithms yeah because
yeah you would have uh this uh yeah like
whatever you can express in this
tractable fragment and then the rest
yeah we just use uh the bites
the I think I saw on I saw on one of
your slides you're talking about um like
get to do some division by a factorial
and something like that but you still
said the overall time was polom and I
guess I didn't
quite yeah so here the input is given in
unary because otherwise even the outputs
would be exponential if you want to com
compute uh like answer to combinatorial
question and you give the input in
binary then uh the numbers can be
massive
yes first of all nice talk uh a question
about hardness so um as far as I know
only um unnatural Sharpie one heart
problems has been known is there any
progress did you find a natural Sharpie
one heart problem I think the one from
uh your paper is the most natural right
this
fo3 so the the ear on to show that
transitivity uh yeah that would be nice
okay so you don't know know but it's
interesting problem yeah actually I do
have a second question so the the
website you alluded to sounds very
intriguing so do you automatically
generate those formulas that try to much
um and you you just amount to you find
the
match uh well so yeah yeah so we
generate them exhaustively and we have
like base to prune the space because if
you didn't prune it in smart Bas you
would mostly end up with sentences that
give the same uh
cences so when you uh you can imagine
you have the different cells and then
you have like parameters that give uh
like the model count among them and
that's can be thought of as like like
canonical
representation that allows you to check
which uh at least sufficient conditions
for checking which uh sentences will
lead to the same
sence so if I understand correctly one
of your assumption is that the schema is
given so you know which how many binary
relations you have yeah so we keep
increasing that uh like the itative
depending like
style very fun website thank you
thanks
thank you for the talk couple of
comments rather than questions for the
sampling we have the 01 law for first
order logic I'm assuming you don't have
function symbols in your vocabulary
right yeah so the sampling becomes
interesting really only for the
sentences that have probability zero
otherwise you just pick at
random model and that's not that
probability one would satisfy the
sentence is that correct
so so most of the exams you had are all
having probability zero yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think that's true if you go to
large uh domain sizes yes but then
something interesting happens in between
in between okay the other thing is a
long time ago 1966 Dana Scott studied
first order logic with two
variables uh you probably know that he
gave a very interesting reduction to the
fragment conjunctions for all for all
and for all exists has this been used in
this work at all but that he added new
um predicate symbol so the the schema
changed have you is that useful so that
was used in this paper uh Beam at all so
it was used there and I just use it that
was the step from the universal
Quantified fo2 to the full fo2 this used
it like
this thank
you we have more
questions I do have
a sorry I'm just fascinated by this work
so in in enumerative combinatorics uh
people look for elegant proofs uh and
all the algorith as far as I know they
are so opaque for um symmetric mod count
do you have any thoughts about this
there a hope for a clean algor at
enumerative combinatorics people can say
we're going to use this automated system
from now on yeah that's a good question
so vak and his student uh Al dkas I
think he had a paper but they were
looking for uh recurrences for these
model counting problems and that's very
interesting work but it cannot really
cover yet any like oh they haven't shown
it covers like the full C2 or I think
not even fo2 unless I'm mistaken but
it's going in very interesting Direction
what we tried was we tried to just
conject
be recurrences using like uh these tools
and yeah we got the right ones for the
known problems but of course that was
without proof that was more like
conjecture
making um so we go for a break now and
come
back come back at 11:20 right so we can
take the other questions